Autopsy reports usually confirm what's already
known about a celebrity's death. But some reveal
secrets that the public — and in at least one
case, the celebrity themself — may not have known.
"Just take a look at these fans who spent the
night out here mourning the loss of Paul Walker."
Paul Walker died as a passenger in a car driven
by his friend Roger Rodas on November 30,
2013. The vehicle collided with a lamp post and
two trees in the San Fernando Valley suburb of
Valencia, California. After striking the
second tree, the car burst into flames,
and both Walker and Rodas were declared dead
by Los Angeles County firefighters who arrived
on the scene. While it was believed that Walker
died as a result of the collision, a report from
the Los Angeles County Coroner showed that the
40-year-old suffered a far more agonizing fate.
As the report reveals, his body was found
lying across the passenger seat of the car.
Walker had suffered extensive "thermal injuries,"
including charred skin and fractured bones that,
according to the medical examiner, were
heat-related. Soot was found in his trachea,
which indicated that he was able to breathe,
and was therefore alive, while the car was
on fire. His bloodstream also had 14% carbon
monoxide saturation — 12% higher than normal
levels. The report ultimately cited traumatic and
thermal injuries as the cause of Walker's death.
It was a tragic end to an acclaimed career:
Oscar-winning actor Philip Seymour Hoffman
was found dead from a drug overdose at the age of
46 on February 2, 2014. As his longtime partner,
costume designer Mimi O'Donnell noted in an essay
for Vogue, Hoffman had struggled with substance
abuse during his college years. After that, he
remained sober for decades before experiencing
several personal struggles that led to a relapse,
followed by a return to treatment in 2013.
In late February 2014, the New York Medical
Examiner's Office issued its findings in a report,
which stated that Hoffman's death was the
result of an accidental overdose caused by
acute mixed drug intoxication. A combination of
various narcotics, including heroin, cocaine,
amphetamines, and benzodiazepines, may have
been taken sequentially in a relatively
short period. Chronic drug users may not
feel the immediate effects of substances,
so they will mix more drugs in order
to produce a high. As chief medical
correspondent for CNN Dr. Sanjay
Gupta said in a 2014 interview,
"They're not feeling it, but it's
still having an impact on their
ability to breathe, and that's the real problem."
On January 9, 2022, comedian and "Full House"
star Bob Saget was found unresponsive in a hotel
room in Orlando, Florida. The 65-year-old
was pronounced dead on the scene of what
was initially reported to be blunt-force
trauma to the head. The Orange County
Sheriff's Office conducted an investigation
and relayed their findings to Saget's family,
who issued a statement in February
of that year. The family wrote.
"They have concluded that he accidentally
hit the back of [his] head on something,
thought nothing of it, and went to sleep."
His family went on to clarify that no drugs
or alcohol were involved. The New York Times
also noted that the sheriff's office
dismissed any suggestion of foul play.
The autopsy report gave a more detailed account
of the extent of Saget's injuries. Dr. Joseph
Stephany, the chief medical examiner for Orange
and Osceola counties, wrote that he suffered
a serious blow to the head — one that caused
fractures to the back, right side, and front
of his skull. The blow also led to vein rupture,
which caused blood to pool in the space between
the brain and the surrounding membrane. Stephany
concluded that the injuries were most likely
caused by a fall, though a New York Times article
shared observations from medical professionals
who questioned the idea that Saget would have
gone to sleep after experiencing such an injury.
On March 23, 2016, Emmy-winning comedian Garry
Shandling told a doctor friend that he was
experiencing pain in his legs and shortness of
breath. The friend advised him to seek medical
attention, but Shandling was hesitant. When his
condition failed to improve the following day,
Shandling called 911 and collapsed during the
call. He was rushed to St. John's Hospital
in Santa Monica, California, where he
was pronounced dead at the age of 66.
"Garry is gone, and this just doesn't seem real."
Shandling's death was initially reported as
a heart attack, but the Los Angeles County
Coroner's Office opened an investigation to
determine the actual cause. The office issued
their findings in December 2016, which noted that
a toxicology report found only therapeutic amounts
of Xanax and opiates in his system, which, as
TMZ noted, were prescribed for then-recent dental
work. The report also found that Shandling
had died from a pulmonary embolism caused
by a blood clot in his lungs. The clot, also
known as deep vein thrombosis, developed in
his legs during a trip to Hawaii, which was
when he had first reported feeling unwell.
According to the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention, blood clots can form when individuals
must travel while sitting in a confined space,
such as a flight. In many cases, the clots
dissolve on their own, but some break apart and
move to the lungs, causing a pulmonary embolism.
Actor Tyler Sanders' impressive list of
television credits included a starring
role on the Amazon series "Just Add Magic:
Mystery City" and guest appearances on "9-1-1:
Lone Star" and "Fear the Walking Dead" —
all of which he'd achieved while still a
teenager. Unfortunately, Sanders also struggled
with both depression and substance abuse,
the latter of which contributed to
his untimely death at the age of 18.
Sanders was found dead in his Los Angeles home on
June 16, 2022. Six months later, the Los Angeles
Department of Medical Examiner-Coroner issued
its findings. The report noted that Sanders had
a history of drug use, and that he had informed
a friend the night before his death that he had
reported using fentanyl. The same friend found
Sanders at his home and called paramedics,
who pronounced the actor dead. Drug paraphernalia
was visible and identified at the scene.
Medical examiner Robyn Parks wrote in the
report that fentanyl, which is a synthetic
opioid, can be 50 to 100 times as potent as the
pharmaceutical painkiller morphine. She concluded,
"Based on the history, circumstances,
and examination as I currently know them,
the manner of death is accidental."
On August 5, 2022, Daytime Emmy-winning actor
Anne Heche was involved in a series of vehicular
accidents before colliding with a house that
caused both the car she was driving and the
building to catch fire. It took firefighters
45 minutes to extricate Heche from the vehicle,
during which she suffered both
severe burns and smoke inhalation.
"And even if they'd known for certain
someone was in the wrecked car,
it probably would not have changed what happened."
Treatment at an area hospital and burn center
revealed that the extent of the damage included a
traumatic brain injury. After lapsing into a coma,
Heche was declared legally dead on August 11.
Law enforcement officials stated at the
time of the accident that Heche was under
the influence of narcotics, and a preliminary
blood analysis appeared to show the presence of
cocaine and other substances in her system.
However, a report issued on December 6,
2022 from the Los Angeles County Department
of Medical Examiner-Coroner revealed that
only an inactive element of cocaine and
marijuana were found in her system. This
meant that she had not used either
substance at the time of the crash.
The official cause of death was listed
as smoke inhalation and thermal injuries,
with first-degree burns covering over 40% of her
body. Heche also suffered a sternal fracture,
which made it difficult for her to breathe and,
according to the coroner's office,
contributed significantly to her death.
Fans of Anton Yelchin were stunned by news of the
"Star Trek" actor's death in 2016. The young star
died after his own car pinned him against a
security fence at his home in Studio City,
California. A police investigation and subsequent
report from the Los Angeles County Coroner's
office found that the 27-year-old actor died
as a result of blunt traumatic asphyxia,
or intense compression of his chest. The report
suggested that at 1 a.m. on June 19, 2016,
Yelchin may have stepped out of his 2015 Jeep
Grand Cherokee to check his gate or mail. The
vehicle, which was parked on a steep incline on
his driveway, may not have been properly parked,
and it rolled backward, crushing him
against a brick fence pillar and the gate.
The report stated that Yelchin's death was
accidental and took place within a minute
after the car struck him. CBS News noted in
2016 that 850,000 vehicles — the majority of
which were 2014 and 2015 Jeep Grand Cherokees —
were under investigation by the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration because of their
electronic gearshift. Yelchin's family settled a
wrongful death lawsuit against Fiat Chrysler
Automobiles for undisclosed terms in 2018.
The legacy of the popular, Emmy-winning musical
comedy-drama series "Glee" was tempered by
the fact that three of its cast members
died. Naya Rivera was one of those actors,
who played cheerleader Santana Lopez
on the series. She died while spending
time with her four-year-old son at
California's Lake Piru on July 8, 2020.
A report from the Ventura County Medical
Examiner revealed that Rivera and her son,
Josey, were swimming in Lake Piru. After helping
her son back into their rented boat, Rivera was
unable to return to the craft. The report stated
that her son saw her struggle and call for help
before disappearing into the water; her body
was found five days later on July 13, 2020.
According to the report, Rivera suffered from
vertigo and had small amounts of the anti-anxiety
medication diazepam in her system, along with
an appetite suppressant. Neither of these was
cited as a factor in her death, however, which was
instead attributed solely to accidental drowning.
Actor Michael K. Williams overcame a
debilitating struggle with substance
abuse to become a powerful presence in
numerous acclaimed television series. He
is known for roles like the vengeful Omar
Little in "The Wire," powerful gangster
Albert "Chalky" White in "Boardwalk
Empire," and his Emmy-nominated turn
as Montrose Freeman in "Lovecraft Country."
Williams was also dedicated to supporting
individuals — especially young people — through
nonprofits like his Making Kids Win initiative.
"Why is this not here for my young people,
my children. There's nothing for them to do."
Additionally, he explored the circumstance
that often brought young people to the
drug trade and juvenile justice
system through Emmy-nominated
documentaries like the Vice News
series "Black Market." Tragically,
Williams was found dead at the age of 54 in
his Brooklyn apartment on September 6, 2021.
A report from the New York City Office
of the Chief Medical Examiner found
that Williams had died of acute drug
intoxication after using heroin laced
with the synthetic opioid fentanyl
and an analog, parafluorofentanyl.
His death was ruled accidental. Fans and
co-stars alike paid tribute to Williams.
In 2023, the U.S. Attorney's Office for the
Southern District of New York reported that
Irvin Cartagena, part of the drug trafficking
organization that sold heroin to Williams,
pleaded guilty to charges of
conspiring to distribute narcotics.
Authorities were called to the home of Cameron
Boyce on the afternoon of July 6, 2019, after
the actor was found unresponsive. Boyce, who was
best known for shows such as "Jessie" and Disney's
"Descendants," was pronounced dead on the scene,
shocking fans and co-stars alike. While tributes
poured in on social media, the Los Angeles County
Coroner's Office performed an autopsy. Officials
were reluctant to release a cause of death
due to a need for "further investigation."
The coroner's report, issued on July 30, 2019,
noted that Boyce suffered from epilepsy and
that his death was natural and caused by a
seizure related to the condition. A statement
from his family corroborated that finding,
adding that he died in his sleep from Sudden
Unexpected Death in Epilepsy. According to the
Centers for Disease Control and Prevention,
this little-known condition affects
approximately one out of every
1,000 individuals with epilepsy. The exact cause
is not known, but the CDC explains that death may
occur when a seizure causes an interruption
to breathing patterns or heart rhythm.
South African model turned actor Charlbi
Dean was on the brink of stardom thanks
to a role in the 2022 Palme d'Or-winning
film "Triangle of Sadness." But her ascent
was cut short on August 29, 2022, when
her representation reported that she had
died of a sudden and unexpected illness
at a New York City hospital. Her cause
of death wasn't revealed until December of
that year when a spokesperson from the New
York Medical Examiner's Office stated that
the 32-year-old died of bacterial sepsis.
The examiner's office revealed that Dean, who
also had a recurring role as Syonide on "Black
Lightning" had been infected by Capnocytophaga,
a bacterium commonly found in both animals and
humans. The bacteria is related to a variety
of health problems, and in certain cases,
it can cause serious illnesses. The examiner's
office reported that the sepsis occurred because
Dean was vulnerable to infections after having
her spleen removed following a 2009 car accident
in Cape Town. That same accident also left her
with multiple broken bones and a collapsed lung.
The circumstances surrounding the
1981 death of Natalie Wood continue
to fascinate classic Hollywood and true
crime devotees alike. The Oscar-nominated
actor drowned while on a boat trip with
her husband Robert Wagner on November 29,
1981. An autopsy report issued at the time by
Los Angeles County coroner Thomas Noguchi cited
accidental drowning and hypothermia as the
cause of her death. The report also noted,
"Superficial skin bruises on the extremities
and abrasions on the left side of her face."
These were attributed to injuries sustained
at the time of Wood's drowning. A number
of prescription drugs were found in her
system, including the painkiller Darvon,
medication to combat seasickness and
insomnia, and two unidentified pills.
The superficial injuries on Wood's body remained
a pressing question for those who believed there
was more to her demise than drowning. When
the Los Angeles County Sheriff's Office
reopened the inquiry in 2011, these bruises
and other marks were suggested as supporting
evidence that Wood may have been injured
prior to entering the water. As a result,
the cause of death was changed to "drowning
and other undetermined factors," though no
conclusive evidence of another cause
was, or has yet to be presented.
"Natalie Wood was also loved by a world-full
of audiences, and they too, will miss her."
Cult movie fans remember actor Yvette
Vickers as the star of such '50s science
fiction favorites as "Attack of the 50-Foot
Woman" and "Attack of the Giant Leeches." The
actor and former Playboy Playmate achieved
a greater if more tragic notoriety in death
when she was found at her Beverly Hills home
on April 27, 2011. A concerned neighbor who
noted that the 82-year-old Vickers had not
been seen for several months entered the
actor's house and found her remains, which
were in an advanced state of decomposition.
According to a report by the Los Angeles County
Coroner's Office, the cause of Vickers' death
was heart disease. However, the body was so
decomposed that the coroner's office described
it as appearing to be mummified. In fact, it was
in a state of decay so advanced that initially,
it was impossible to determine whether
the body was male or female. Eventually,
dental records helped to confirm that the body
was that of Vickers, but the exact date of death
was impossible to determine. Lt. Tony Carranza of
the Los Angeles Police Department told ABC News,
"Once you start to have decomposition,
it becomes more difficult but it looks like
it's probably six months; it's hard to say."
Fans of Stephen "tWitch" Boss experienced
shock and dismay upon learning of his death by
self-inflicted gunshot wound. According to the Los
Angeles County Medical Examiner's report, no other
factors contributed to his death on December
13, 2022, which was confirmed as a suicide.
The 40-year-old dancer and "Ellen DeGeneres
Show" DJ did not have any drugs or alcohol in
his system and his body showed no other signs
of trauma or wounds. Additionally, Boss' wife,
dancer and choreographer Allison Holker,
told law enforcement that her husband did not
have a "history of suicide attempts or suicidal
ideation." She also confirmed that he did not have
any mental health problems or financial or marital
issues that might have contributed to his suicide.
"Stephen was an incredible father
and an incredible husband."
A frequent guest star and recurring
player on numerous television series,
actor Heath Freeman appeared on "ER," "NCIS," and
"Without a Trace." He also enjoyed a three-episode
arc between 2005 and 2007 as the sadistic
serial killer Howard Epps on "Bones." Sadly,
Freeman earned more headlines for his untimely
death at the age of 41 on November 14, 2021.
The actor was pronounced dead after being found
unresponsive in his home in Austin, Texas. Several
months later, the Travis County Medical Examiner
made public its findings in an autopsy report.
TMZ published the report on March 9, 2022, which
revealed that he died of a combination of alcohol,
narcotics, and prescription medication. Among
the drugs found in Freeman's system at the time
of the autopsy were fentanyl, cocaine,
oxycodone, hydrocodone, and alprazolam,
which is better known by the name brand,
Xanax. The report also noted that police
discovered both Xanax and oxycodone pills
at Freeman's home. Opiates like oxycodone
and benzodiazepines like Xanax are dangerous and
potentially lethal when combined with alcohol,